life is hard for most guys okay let's  remove ourselves out of this for a  second so we'll remove ourselves out  because I'm thinking it from my  perspective right  but I would still say that that  expectations are higher and maybe their  standards are raised but what are you  what are your reality what do you get in  re in the real world your results and  the results don't match the expectations  or the standards that they play well  I've always said that to him and I've  said do your do your expectations match  your results you said you want that guy  that that  XYZ I'm like okay but do your results  match that and a lot of the time they  don't but they still want it and which  is why so many women as they get older  become are still single and become in my  personal point of view bitter because  they started making expectations for  themselves and standards for themselves  that they wouldn't that that were never  realistic in the first place